[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
ich habe neulich am wochenende fallen
droht zubereitet weil nämlich die
bäckereien zu hatten es war ein feiertag
und dann habe ich mir gedacht mensch
machen wir doch barcelona flamatt es ist
schon richtig lustig ist flüssiges brot
ich mag das wort nicht aber ein anderes
wort beschreibt die konsistenz einfach
nicht also ein schönes flüssiges brot
aus der pfanne könnt ihr super
vorbereiten und die mädels also samira
und sie hatten auch super viel spaß
dabei mehr zu helfen
ich zeig euch mal die zutaten die habe
ich persönlich immer zu hause das heißt
immer dann wenn man aber kein brot da
haben und ich ein bisschen zeit habe
mache ich dieses planen brot für den
teig nämlich einen würfel hefe 450 gramm
warmes wasser einen teelöffel zucker 900
gramm mehl ich habe jetzt dinkelmehl ein
teelöffel backpulver 270 gramm dies
bereits warm 40 gramm sonnenblumenöl und
einem esslöffel salz
ich gebe es hier die hefe einfach in
rührschüssel wie immer könnt ihr den tag
auch mit einer hand verkneten das wasser
kommt jetzt direkt dazu und da solltet
ihr einfach immer nur darauf achten dass
das wasser nicht zu heiß ist also
wirklich mal war der zucker mit rein und
jetzt ganz kurz auflösen
ich muss dir sagen dass ich die
frauenhilfe hab ich friere hilfe gerne
auf vorrat ein wenig nämlich keine
frische da haben nämlich sein voraus
dass sich löst die jetzt hier einfach im
warmen wasser nur wenn ihr daran denkt
könnte es auch am abend vorher einen
kleinen kühlschrank stellen zum auftauen
oder eben im warmen wasser jetzt
aufbauen
[Musik]
hier vermisse ich jetzt schon mal die
trockenen zutaten also mädel backpulver
und salz
es geht nach ziemlich viel salz aus aber
ich habe ja auch ein kilogramm also
soviel ist es doch nicht unter geschmack
passt dann perfekt es gebe ich jetzt
hier mit rein und je nach milchsorte
kann sein dass sie einfach bis zu 50
gramm mehr oder weniger braucht ich habs
jetzt bei mir schon getestet wie gesagt
mit dinkelmehl da passt die menge
perfekt wenn jetzt weizen habt kann sein
dass ich einfach ein bisschen mehr
braucht weil der eben mehr flüssigkeit
bindet und schlüssigkeit einfach
benötigt dann gebe ich hier die zwei
einreihen
sie sorgen dafür dass der teig wirklich
schön locker wird die milch und das öl
und da habe ich jetzt einfach ein
sonnenblumenöl weil es geschmacksneutral
ist das war es schon ganz auskotzen und
jetzt einfach den teig verkneten
entweder mit der hand fünf bis zehn
minuten oder eben der küchenmaschine ich
habe es hier einfach noch die 34 grad
eingestellt so kann der trägt direkt
vorwärmen und geht später besser auf
[Musik]
ich nehme jetzt einfach so ein bisschen
back trend bray und kann hier noch schön
die beste abkratzen
und das ist jetzt so ein brot es reicht
also wir waren zu dritt drei erwachsene
und zwei kinder und hatten noch was
übrig als es hätten noch ein erwachsener
oder nochmal zwei kinder hätten damit
essen können ich weiß nicht wie viel ihr
morgens es aber für uns war es echt die
perfekte portion und wir hatten sogar
für den nächsten tag noch was übrig und
das kann man dann einfach am nächsten
tag perfekt entweder im backofen kurz
auf backen oder in so einem toaster das
funktioniert prima ihr seht es ist ein
weiter teig darf ruhig auch etwas weich
bleiben auch wenn er dadurch ein
bisschen klebt so kann hier die schüssel
schön fetten und versuchen den teig zu
einer kugel zusammen
ansonsten nehmen da einfach ein bisschen
mädel zur hilfe aber ich lass den jetzt
hat sich nicht gerne lieber etwas
weicher damit sie eben auch schön
fluffig und luftig werden reinlegen mit
fett besprühen so trocknet die
oberfläche nicht aus und ich werde jetzt
einfach bei der stufe im backofen
aufgehen lassen da braucht es nämlich
wirklich nur 30 minuten statt eine
stunde
ihr könnt aber auch gerne abdecken bei
raumtemperatur oder an dem warmen
kuscheligen ort einfach für eine schöne
aufgehen lassen
er stufe muss man den teig auch nicht
abdecken also da kann man wirklich die
oberfläche offen lassen
denn es kommt ja wasserdampf dazu und
der sorgt dafür dass der teig schnell
und gut aufgeht oder dabei auszutrocknen
das perfekte klima sozusagen wasser ist
drin jetzt nur noch einstellen
so wie der hefeteig bereits nach einer
halben stunde aus aber mein gott das ist
immer so sind diese satisfied mind
dieses war okay jetzt verwende ich etwas
mehl
wie gesagt ist der teig ja auch recht
weich ich verteile von immer so schön
und jetzt ausschütten
ich sag nichts wir machen ein f im
moment drauf
ein mossad des fan videos auf you tube
wisst ihr warum ich hefeteig leben darum
ok ich dachte sich selbstvergessen
hänger und ich freue mich hier einfach
welchen mit etwa 120 gramm
ihr könnt sie gerne abbiegen oder nach
augenmaß arbeiten und wenn ihr sagt ihr
seid im augenmaß portionieren nicht ganz
so gut dann macht ihr es so dass ihr
praktisch hier eine rolle daraus formt
und dann stücke abschneidet oder er
formt ein rundes in runden kreis und
nehmen zum beispiel einem torten
einteiler und hab dann die portionen
oder nehmt euch einfach eine waage und
wägt ab sondern ist einfach diese kreise
formen diese kugeln formen könnte auch
so machen
von samira und ella auch richtig süß
gemacht also ich lass dir dann auch
recht am wochenende einfach mit backen
denn die kids haben spaß dabei und dann
sehen sie auch wie brot hergestellt wird
wissen welche zutaten reinkommen und sie
es uns dann eben auch viel viel lieber
wir machen wir haben nicht mal
ausgeschlafen und da haben wir gemerkt
dass der weg so machen dass ich so von
außen so oder so und dann geht es
deswegen auch kein mehl mit diesen
arbeiten sie immer gleichmäßig 3 mm
[Musik]
edelstahl falsch machen weil damit es
nicht verlassen
[Musik]
aber nur bis zum schluss das ist von
vorne bis hinten so drüber
nächstes jetzt schon reichen wenn ihr
mal schön von fahrern ein bisschen das
macht auch die das kann man einfach eine
edelstahl pfanne warum aber sollen
geschichten voller geschichte okay nun
einfach unfair sie das nicht an
da könnte ich ja so ein kleines blech
nehmen und pizza blech zum beispiel oder
auch ein großes ofen blech einfach mit
mir freuen denn wichtig ist damit die
wirklich auch schön luftig werden die
noch mal aufleben zu lassen als mit ein
bisschen abstand hier aufs blech ihr
könnt auch immer ganz gut zwei
gleichzeitig machen und da gucke ich
immer das nicht so viel mehl auf der
matte ist dann geht es besser praktisch
umdrehen und dann die hand so rund um
den tag legen und einfach kugeln formen
und die finger die transportieren
praktisch die oberfläche immer wieder
nach unten so dass sich die teig kugel
auch schön glättet und da sieht es so
aus das macht dann auch spaß an einem
sonntagmorgen die ich somit wissen teig
zu beschäftigen so ein schöner start in
den tag findet
das war an dem tag soll erstmals ein
schöner ausflug zur bäckerei wieso hey
wir laufen heute alle gemeinsam zur
bäckerei und samir am roller oder
inliner ellar mit ihrem fahrrad und dann
standen aber vom bäcker und der war
einfach zu und ich hey wir laufen wieder
nach hause kamen wir machen brot
waldspaziergang dann darf mein erstes
vielleicht schon mal wieder in den ofen
zurück also entweder abdecken wieder mit
einem tuch zum beispiel und etwa 20 25
minuten aufgehen lassen oder nochmal im
dampf backofen für zehn minuten das
reicht dann auch schon
[Musik]
ach sehen sie schön aussehen nicht schön
aus so sehen schön aus und ich mache sie
zu ich werde jetzt gleich vier bruder
auf einmal auspacken und nehmen wir
schon mal vier teig belchen und den rest
packe ich wieder zurück also immer schön
wieder abdecken oder einen ofen stellen
damit sie einfach nicht austrocknen und
schön weiter aufgehen kann
so und jetzt habe ich mit den kindern so
gemacht denn wenn ich jetzt den kindern
sagt samira el holt mal den teig auf 5
mm dicke aus hat jetzt natürlich schnell
dass es nicht so nicht so gleichmäßig
ausgerollt wird und das ist jetzt auch
das geheimnis hinter dem brot das heißt
richtig schön gleichmäßig ausräumen
damit das brot auch in der pfanne
gleichmäßig backt also nehme ich hier
meine abstands ringe oder ihr könnt auch
tölzer benutzen ihr könnt zum beispiel
aus dem baumarkt holzholen mit 5 mm
stärke
habt ihr auch teilweise einfach selbst
gemacht oder wie gesagt einfach die
ringe für den ausbau starb die werden
hier drauf gesetzt und auf den außen
scharf drauf gerollt und dann habt ihr
hier praktisch immer diesen 5 mm abstand
und könnt wirklich alles perfekt
gleichmäßig ausrollen
also jetzt etwas mehr nehmen dann zack
zack fünf millimeter
da können die kinder wirklich schön mit
helfen ohne dass eben was schief geht
[Musik]
ich nehme jetzt hier einfach meinen
gusseisen britta weil er schon groß ist
ich habe diese rechteckige pfanne und
habe einfach so viel platz wie möglich
ihr könnt auch einen teppan yaki pfanne
nehmen ich habe sie bei mir zu hause
also ich bin hier auch zu hause aber in
der armenküche als er gefrühstückt haben
habe ich wie gesagt auf dem tab an jacke
grill gemacht supercool
ihr könnt aber auch ganz einfach eine
beschichtete pfanne nehmen also hier ist
es wirklich komplett egal ich finde es
nur praktisch wenn man vier bis fünf
gleichzeitig auspacken kann weil man
dann eben schneller zum frühstücken
kommt ok jetzt nehmt ihr das hier ich
habe es bereits auf mittel hohe hitze
erwärmt
da muss ich jetzt echt sagen ihr braucht
keinen patch dafür also wirklich einfach
trocken auspacken und ich sag
normalerweise immer nicht pfannen und
töpfe leer erwärmen
ohne inhalt passt einfach auf dass ihr
nicht überhitzt also jetzt nicht auf
power boost wie es jetzt sturm machen
würde sondern einfach auch mittel hohe
hitze langsam erwärmen so dass einfach
der bräter sich nicht überhitzt das ist
so das einzige geheimnis dahinter und
auch eure beschichtete pfanne und ich
lege jetzt die hier rein
ich glaube die nächsten rolle ich etwas
längliche aus dann passt auch mit 4
jetzt wagte sie einfach von beiden
seiten für etwa zwei bis drei minuten
aus also ich lasse jetzt hier liegen die
erste seite packt dann tricks um und je
nachdem welches material ihr habt kann
sein dass er früher oder eben später
fertig so dass war es in der
zwischenzeit wurde ich die anderen aus
[Musik]
perfekt schaut euch mal die farbe an
ganz schön noch die zweite seite
ausbacken
[Musik]
ich bin jetzt schon fertig als ich jetzt
ein bisschen länger als eine stunde
gebraucht in der zwischenzeit habe ich
noch andere sachen schon gedreht und
rezepte vorbereitet und im prinzip ist
es wirklich ein rezept was super einfach
und ganz schnell geht und ihr könnt
sogar wenn ihr wollt den teig am abend
zuvor vorbereiten
am besten mit der halben hefe menge den
teig in den kühlschrank stellen und am
nächsten morgen dann im prinzip nur noch
die bällchen formen ausrollen und
auspacken oder ihr könnt sogar den teig
aufgehen lassen welchen formen abdecken
kühlschrank in den kühlschrank stellen
und dann am nächsten tag nur noch aus
rollen also da könnt ihr euch wirklich
auch ein bisschen zeit und arbeit am
sonntagmorgen sparen kannst länger
schlafen und ich habe es ja jetzt
praktisch direkt nach dem backen ich
hier auf dem abkühlen gitter gesetzt
damit sie nicht so schwitzen
hier mache ich jetzt auch schon mal aus
die sind nämlich auch gleich durch und
dann sobald sie ein bisschen abgekühlt
sind können dass er auch gerne
übereinander stapeln was ich jetzt mache
vor dem servieren einfach noch so ein
bisschen nur das mehl abklopfen was
einfach so beim ausrollen noch über war
aber ich will erst nach dem backen
abklopfen denn das mädel verhindert
natürlich auch das ankleben und jetzt
kommt's versuchen uns mal richtig
schönes lockeres ja stets daran
probieren
okay kommt war
schön locker und luftig und bei ella
mache ich sogar gern so dass ich es
einfach mit einem messer auf schneit und
ihre salami oder ihre tomaten hier
einfach rein fülle und dann hat sie
praktisch wiederum sandwich direkt und
am nächsten tag könnt ihr es auch
wunderbar nochmal im ofen auf backen
oder im toaster aufbacken also wenn ihr
was übrig habt ansonsten ist er jetzt
einfach gleich probieren
und nicht zuviel salz so ein esslöffel
sei schon viel aus aber auf die
müllmenge braucht ihr auf jeden fall es
lassen
also viel spaß beim nachbacken eures
pfannen brotes basel aber wie gesagt auf
türkisch ich finde es erinnert auch so
ein bisschen annahmen boden an dieses
indische pfannen brot wobei die meist
noch etwas dünner gemacht werden so
knuspriger sind und ich finde es einfach
toll wenn ihr mal keine lust habt zum
bäcker zu gehen kein brot da habt macht
einfach viel spaß beim nachmachen postet
auf jeden fall eure fotos verlinkt mich
drauf und wir sehen uns wieder beim
nächsten mal kaffee und lasst eure
kinder mit backen die können das
wirklich wunderbar es macht ihnen spaß
und führt sie einfach so ein bisschen an
die küche ran und ja dann habt ihr euch
auch später ganz fleißige helferlein in
der küche
[Musik]